>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Carla Davis-Castro: Welcome
to the Library of Congress
and our celebration of Native
American Heritage month.
Our committee is pleased to
have two impactful speakers
with us today, which
we will be filming.
We would like to
thank our sponsor,
the Office of Equal
Employment Opportunity
and Diversity Programs,
and our sponsor and host,
the Law Library of Congress
for supporting this event.
Please take some time,
if you haven't already,
to see some of the items
that we have on display.
We have some items from
geography and maps division
and we also have some
materials from the Law Library
of Congress relating
to the Seminole Tribe.
And to get us started, we're
going to watch just a short,
introductory video
about the work
of the Indian Law
Resource Center.
[ Music Playing ]
>> These are the core beliefs of
the Indian Law Resource Center.
For more than 30 years, the
Center has been a global force,
challenging and building legal
frameworks, to enhance the lives
of indigenous peoples.
One of the major causes of
the economic and social ills
within native communities
is the unfair legal rules
that apply only to native
peoples in the United States.
We have taken on cases on
behalf of the Timbisha Shoshone,
and the Mohawk Nations,
and others with the goal
of changing some of these laws.
We also seek to strengthen
sovereignty rights
so that tribes can better
protect their people.
This is more critical
now than ever.
>> One in three native women
will be raped in her lifetime
and three out of five will
be physically assaulted.
The center's hallmark
work is related
to the United Nation's
Declaration on the Rights
of Indigenous Peoples.
>> Robert T. Coulter: We wanted
to be sure, and we wanted
to establish legal rules
that would make it clear
that indigenous peoples
really do own their land.
They really do have full
and complete legal
rights to those lands.
But they have rights that can
be protected in the courts.
Rights that are protected
by definite rules of law
that can't just be thrown out or
ignored by courts or countries
and their governments.
>> The declaration was adopted
by the UN General
Assembly in 2007.
>> President Barack Obama:
And as you know, in April,
we announced that we were
reviewing our position
on the UN Declaration on the
Rights of Indigenous Peoples.
And today, I can announce
that the United States
is lending its support
to this declaration.
>> This is just a
snapshot of the work coming
out of both the Helena, Montana
and Washington DC offices.
We at the Indian Law
Resource Center are experts
in Indian law, working
to protect
and preserve indigenous
peoples and their communities.
Our ultimate goal is to
make positive contributions
that will have lasting effects.
Visit www.indianlaw.org.
>> Carla Davis-Castro:
Our speakers today are Armstrong
A. Wiggins, the director
of the Indian Law Resource
Center, Washington DC office.
Born in Nicaragua, Mr.
Wiggins is a Moskito Indian
from the village of
Karata in Nicaragua.
He was the founder of the Indian
organization called [foreign
language], and was the
coordinator of municipal affairs
of the east coast for the
government of Nicaragua.
He was also the national
representative
of the regional Indian
organization [foreign language].
Mr. Wiggins was arrested
twice during both the Somoza
and the Sandinista regimes and
became a political prisoner
because of his work to
promote human rights
for his people in Nicaragua.
In 1981, Mr. Wiggins
was forced into exile.
It was at this time that he
began working for the Center
as the director of its Central
and South America program.
For the past 20 years,
he has worked
on numerous human rights cases
involving indigenous peoples,
including the Yano
Nami in Brazil,
the case against Nicaragua in
the inter-American commission
on human rights in 1984,
which led to changes
in the constitution of
Nicaragua for the recognition
of indigenous rights
and the creation
of autonomous indigenous
regions in Nicaragua.
He worked on the case
for the Maya in Belize.
Mr. Wiggins played
a leading role
in the precedent setting
[foreign language]
in the Inter-American System.
And he has also played
a critical role
in the Center's standard setting
work with the United Nations
and the organization
of American States,
particularly regarding the
Declarations on the Rights
of Indigenous Peoples.
He currently supervises the
works of the Center dealing
with human rights,
standards setting,
and multi-lateral
development banks.
Leonardo Crippa is an
international law scholar
and practitioner.
He holds a JD from the
National University of Tucuman
in Argentina, and an LLM
from American University.
As the Center for Justice
and International
Law's staff attorney,
he litigated several
human rights cases
within the Inter-American
Human Right's System.
In his current work
as the senior attorney
of the Indian Law
Resource Center,
he analyzes multi-lateral
development bank's policies,
and continues to
practice international law
within the United Nations
and the Inter-American
Human Rights System.
He is also the author of
papers on constitutional law,
international law,
and multi-lateral
development bank's policies.
They will be interviewed
by Carrie Newton Lyons,
section research manager
and legislative attorney
of the American Law Division
in the Congressional Research
Service here at the library.
She is an enrolled member
of the Cherokee Nation.
Carrie, take it away.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Thank you.
I'd like to first thank
everybody for coming out today
and supporting us for Native
American Heritage Month.
We really appreciate your taking
time today to come and join us.
And we have two fabulous
guests with us.
And thank you both
for coming out.
We are very honored
to have you today.
And I'm just going to jump right
in with the questions right now.
So first-- I also have
to do a disclaimer though
that any views expressed
by me are my own
and are not official
representative
of Congressional
Research Service.
So let me get to the question.
So can you tell us, generally,
about the work that you do
at the Indian Law Resource
Center, and a little bit more
about the structure and how
the organization came to be?
>> Armstrong Wiggins: The Indian
Resource Center is founded
by Robert T. Coulter.
He's a Potowatomi person.
He's also a judge
in this community.
He represents his nation to the
organization of American States
and the United Nations.
Tim went to Columbia Law
School and, from law school,
he realized that one of
the biggest challenges
that indigenous peoples faced
was the very lack of law
that indigenous people
understand.
And the law was very
discriminatory
against indigenous people.
We're talking about the
European legal system that came
to the Americas that
indigenous people had a hard
time understanding.
>> Could you speak up?
>> Armstrong Wiggins: We're
talking about the laws
that came from Europe.
Indigenous peoples had
a hard time fighting
against that system.
In the past, they can
understand their struggle
between the cowboys and Indians.
And you know that
most of the time
that cowboys were the good
guys, Indians was the bad guys.
And so that was a
very heavy challenge.
And when the legal
system come, and very,
very racist legal system
against the Indian government
that existed in this
continent, it was very hard.
First, because they don't
understand the language,
they don't speak English.
And so it was very
discriminatory.
So after Tim went to
law school and came out,
he decided that he needs to form
the Indian Law Resource Center
to represent traditional
Indian governments
against the Washington influence
of how to destroy Indian way
of thinking, Indian philosophy,
Indian way of looking issues.
And so they gave lots of money
to Bureau of Indian Affairs
to destroy traditional
Indian governments.
And you know what happened.
History will tell you what
happened to indigenous people
from this terrible
legal thinking.
And so Tim wanted to create
Indian Law Resource Center
so that we can represent
them for free.
Because lawyers were one
of our Indian worst enemy.
Because they were
represent them, and then,
if they do win a case,
they owe the lawyer more
than what they were
supposed to pay.
And so they didn't get
any benefit from it.
So the Indian Law Resource
Center is a non-profit office
that we don't charge
our clients.
We find our own money to
represent native people.
The other interesting thing is
that we do not accept
government money.
We raise our private
money from foundations,
individuals to represent
Indian governments.
We do not individual,
we represent collective
governments.
So that's how Indian Law
Resource Center was created
and founded in 1978.
Since then, we've been there.
We settle in Washington DC
at the Eastern Market area,
because we're close to
the Library of Congress.
In the old days, we
used to come here a lot.
We used to get to know
everybody at the legal stop.
Now, don't you don't see me
anymore because of internet.
[ Laughing ]
But now we don't come.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Right.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: So that's
the Indian Law Resource Center.
So then Tim decided
to move to Helena,
Montana because there are
more indigenous peoples there
so then work with them closer.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Right.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
And so the office is--
the Washington DC office
deals with the Hill here,
the Congress, the White House,
the OAS, the Organization
of American States because
you have the Inter-American
Commission on Human Rights,
the Inter-American Court,
and the World Bank, and the
Inter-American Development Bank.
All this has to with policy
affecting indigenous people.
Because the bad economic policy
also affect indigenous people,
to take away their land
and their resources.
And a lot of people
still believe
that we're against development.
We are not against development.
We are against the
kind of development
that the capitalist system bring
to the inter-indigenous
community
that take away their land.
So we believe in sustainable
economic development.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Right, right.
Leo, do you have
anything to add?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: Yes.
I have something to add.
Despite the fact
that [inaudible] I found
the Center is unique
in the way it presents
tribes, communities,
because the way the
Center handles the cases,
it's a very long process,
through which the Center
attorneys will, basically,
sit down with the communities
who they are attempting
to represent.
They will assess their-- yes.
The attorneys will
assess their legal means,
the aspirations of
their communities.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Oh, thank you.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: The
legal systems of the country,
with the local council that
the community will select
in the country.
We will build a legal strategy.
And that works.
We, basically, translate
into political strategy,
the political aspiration
of the community based
on international laws,
especially human rights law.
That's unique.
I've done that over
here in the Center,
and I work with [inaudible]
another organization
that also handles
cases internationally.
But the Center is unique
in that way of working
with the communities
from the very beginning
and building the legal
strategy from the bottom.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Well,
this leads-- oh yes.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
And I want to--
I want to add to that
because that is very important
to understand what we do is the
political leader's speeches is
very important to us.
When you are thinking
about environmental issue,
when you thinking about land
rights issue, when you thinking
about how we live collectively
for generations,
in this continent.
So we take that.
We listen to them, and
we turn the project,
their political speeches,
into a legal project
to educate what collective
rights mean, what land surface
or surface mean to them,
as compared to Europeans,
what they mean.
What individual rights verses
collective rights mean.
You know that European doesn't
believe in collective rights.
Everything is individual rights.
We do not really believe that.
We also believe that their
human rights is collective
and individual rights.
You live with community.
You live with your village.
And you protect your
village people,
not just you, individual.
And that's where
unfairness come.
That's where, when
people become rich, rich,
and then you have poor, poor.
You don't have that collectivity
way of sharing your resources
that you have, your
land resources,
whether it's gold, whatever.
So that is why our way
of thinking educate the legal
system in the United States.
And that's what we
call law reform.
Law reform is very important.
And that's how Indian Law
Resource Center challenge the
legal system in the
United States,
and challenge university
law schools.
Because we believe lawyers
have very influential position
in our society in this country.
Lawyers become president.
Lawyers become senators,
most of them.
Lawyers become judges, from
Supreme Court right down.
And if they don't
understand our way of thinking
and the legal way of indigenous
people look at their issues,
their political issues, then,
that's where discrimination
comes, sometimes by ignorance,
not understanding
the power issue.
So that's why the legal project.
And one thing is very important.
We don't tell our
clients what to do.
They tell us what to do.
Because in the past, lawyers
will tell them how they should
think, how they should
do things.
We want them to tell us.
They're our boss.
So that's how we
create a legal policy
to help indigenous
people basic human rights.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Speaking
of law reform and cases, Leo,
can you tell us about some
of the most interesting,
or maybe the most
challenging cases you've had?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: Sure.
I'll tell about the most
challenging one first.
That was the Rapa Nui Case.
Rapa Nui's the native of,
basically, Easter Island.
An island part of the Polynesian
Triangle on the Pacific Ocean.
>> Could you speak up again?
I couldn't hear what that was.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: Rapa Nui?
It's an island in
the Pacific Ocean.
And the native people there
are called Rapa Nui too.
And so the case-- but we
actually didn't have a case,
but we got the request from
the Rapa Nui parliament.
The request, basically, helped
them secure their lands--
regain control over their lands.
Because, in the early '90's,
the Chilean government,
they moved them from
their traditional lands
to a concentration camp in
the island called Hanga Roa.
And in 1966, for the very first
time, they were, basically,
released and were able to
walk free in their own island.
They became, for the very
first time, citizens of Chile.
And so it was around 2009,
we received this request.
We had never heard about them.
I was on vacation in Argentina
and they decided to put me
in a plane and send
to me to Chile
because it was a short flight.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: So your
vacation was cut short?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: Yeah.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: OK.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa:
That's why I remember.
And so, basically, in landed
in this island in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean, a very
small one, with the population
of about 5,000 people, around
4,000 were natives, Rapa Nui.
All of them speak the language.
They're Polynesian.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Leo, can
you speak up a little bit
for the people in the far back?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: And
they decided to go back
to their official lands.
In the past there were
18 traditional lands.
And so they plans to go back.
What they found, in some
cases, were public offices,
in other cases, business.
And their own clan in that
area started to [inaudible].
And so they were in the middle
of that action when
I landed there.
And it was challenging because
I had to assess, as I said,
what were their legal means?
How did Indian Law Resource
Center from Washington
or Helena, Montana
could assist them?
And I found myself visiting each
of the areas having reoccupied
by the Rapa Nui families
and clans.
I knew that Chile was
going to react violently,
because there's a history
of how Chile, they interacts
with the Mapuche people
in the south of Chile.
And so, basically, after
a week of being there,
I flew back to Washington DC,
reported back to Armstrong
and Tim what I was
able to learn,
reported about three
actions that we could take.
One was immediate.
We had to secure
the extra measures
from the Inter-American
Commission on Human Rights here
in Washington DC so that
preventative actions could be
ordered to Chile so the
government of Chile would not,
basically, act violently
against the people of Rapa Nui.
That was around October.
The second action
was, basically,
recover a very important Moai.
Some of you may know--
have heard about the Moai.
It plays a very important
role in the Rapa Nui culture,
in Rapa Nui sense, a traditional
occupation of each of the clans.
And you will find statues
like this all over the island.
They are based on a rectangular
base that is called ahu.
And that's where the
ancestors of each
of the families are buried.
I didn't believe that
until they started
to show me what was below.
And so the second action
was, basically, try to cover
from the [inaudible] one
of the most important Moai
that was removed
from the island.
It was being shown there.
And the third one, which
was the most complex one,
is the determination because
it is an [inaudible] of Chile.
And so the first
one was challenging.
I had to represent
about 4,000 people.
They never took a legal
action against Chile.
They prepared for the
very first time from us.
So I started to get
the power of attorneys
from each of the clans.
And I ended up filing a request
for precautionary measures
with the Inter-American
Commission
for Human Rights here in DC.
After two months of legal
debates, with regard of Chile,
the Commission decided to grant
those protective measures.
By the time it was granted,
the entire island was
already militarized.
There were Special Forces.
And, I'll never forget this,
on December the 3rd of 2009,
there was a huge operation
against each of the families.
And most of them were
removed violently.
And there were shots, people
lost their eyes, and so forth.
Unfortunately, the
precautionary measures were
granted afterwards.
So I wasn't able
to prevent that.
And it was very violent
situation.
But in the end, the armed
forces were moved back
to continental Chile.
The government was
forced to have a dialogue
with the traditional Rapa Nui
authorities for the purpose
of discussing the issues
of their main concern.
That happened for
over four years.
And so I stopped the violence
in the end, but I wasn't able
to stop the most bad operation
that happened against them.
And so that was very
challenging to me.
The most interesting one
case that I have right now is
against Guatemala to report
Inter-American Commission
on Human Rights.
It is represented a small
Maya Q'eqchi' community
in the northern part
of [inaudible].
And it's a case where
this community has been
under a land-titling program
for more than four years
without getting the final
title because of irregularities
in the land surveys
and the land--
>> Carrie N. Lyons: So they're
supposed to get the land,
but they haven't
actually gotten it yet.
OK.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: And,
in the meantime, the Ministry
of Mining has issued permits
to a private mining company
to explore and exploit
legal on the land belonging
to this one community.
And so our lawsuit against
the land titling agency.
We never thought we were going
to win, but we won that case.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Oh, good.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: And after
two years with non-process,
unfortunately, the government
[inaudible] is not enforcing
this court decision and
so we were, basically,
we had to sue the government
for Maya before the
Inter-American Commission.
And this is now an
international case.
We are seeking the international
responsibility of Guatemala
because of the violation
of these community's right
of property over the
lands that they possess.
And it is now in the
responsibility stage.
We won that stage.
The commission has released the
responsibility report saying
that we fulfilled all the
requirements set for the
in American Commission
and Human Rights in May,
Human Rights Treaty,
ratified by Guatemala.
And now we are discussing
the merits.
And it's very interesting
because it touches
the very structure
on how lands are taken away
from indigenous communities,
based on how prevalent
the land survey
and [inaudible] system
works in Guatemala.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Oh, so it
seems like whenever you do take
up cases, that it's a
long-term commitment.
And, you know, some of these
cases can take quite a while
before they are ever resolved.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Yeah, I
remember that Leo came in later,
but Indian Law Resource
Center biggest challenge--
I mean, first of all,
I'm a trained electrical
engineer for my first career.
I never dreamed to be
speaking to you on legal
and human rights issues.
Because we used to-- and my
specialty was in antennae.
I was supposed to be
an astronaut, right?
That was my interest, you know,
an electrical engineer, pilot,
go to Cape Kennedy, and go up.
But my people, the Moskito
people called me back
to come home.
And that's how I get
involved in politics
and end up in jail twice.
And I think one of the
things that very challenging
from Indian Law Resource
Center perspective was
to change things.
And I guess that's what
happened between us,
the Indian Law Resource Center.
I think that one of the thing
that is very important is
to work so close with
our leaders, our people.
And work with them and do
the work that we need to do.
And so our big, big, big first
challenges was in Nicaragua
because of the cold war.
And I'm sure all
of you know that.
That divided us in Nicaragua,
divided Americans here
because of Reagan administration
verses the Sandinista
government, the contras, and
the human rights was divided.
And I was in the
middle of it here,
because I came out of jail here.
And I challenged Senator
Kennedy, Senator McCain,
Senator Dole, everybody
that there was not black
and white in Central America.
There was indigenous people
in the middle of that black
and white, left and right.
And so a lot of people
didn't take side.
And I'm sure today,
in Washington,
you will see what's going on.
During the 80's, something
was going on like that too.
They divide the family,
everybody was divided
because of taking side.
And Indian Law Resource
Center was
in the middle of
that challenges.
And from that challenges,
we have, now, in Nicaragua,
autonomous government
with indigenous people.
We have special system
that was set up.
And our constitution
was improved.
Because I bring cases
against Sandinista government
that changed the Nicaraguan
constitution in 1987,
and more progressive
towards indigenous people.
We brought a legal case
against Yanomami case in Brazil.
That now Yanomami have a
Yanomami park in Brazil.
These were uncontacted
people that we represented.
I went in there,
in their community.
That you have to deal with
them to get their land rights.
Now they have the
Yanomami Park in Brazil,
one of the biggest land, kind
of, rights issue that happened
in Brazil after the
Kayopi in Brazil.
Then we bring the case against
Belize, the Mayan people.
Now they have their
land rights approved
by Belize Supreme Court,
recognized by the regional
court in the Caribbean.
It leads the Mayan people.
Now they have their land rights.
And then we have the biggest
one was Stanley vs. Nicaragua,
which is now the international
community recognized indigenous
people land throughout
the Inter-American system.
And so those are some of the
challenges that we faced.
And we struggled through that.
And get support from the
international community.
And the other challenge was
to create international
development,
international standard,
international declaration.
Which, this is the
United Nation declaration.
And this is the American
declaration on rights
of indigenous people that
was just adopted last year,
in the general assembly
of the [inaudible].
So all this is here
if you people want
to read what these declaration.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: I think
they're out-- outside.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Outside.
And so, this is what
Leo was talking
about just not too long ago.
So we face a lot of
challenges ahead of us still.
And you see from even from
yesterday at the White House,
we still faces a lot
of discrimination,
a lot of struggle that we need
to overcome regarding
our people rights.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Can
you tell us about some
of your experiences working
with tribal governments
in the United States on VAWA.
Because that's a bit
of a success story.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Yes,
that's VAWA is a big success
story, but it's ongoing.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Yeah.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: And a
lot of challenges that we face
in the United States
because, as you know,
VAWA was first introduced
by Senator Biden in 1994.
And they went through a lot
of process till 2013,
VAWA was approved.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Right,
so VAWA is the Violence
Against Women Act.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Violence
Against Women Act, yes.
1994 and 2013.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Right,
reauthorization in 2013, yeah.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
And so as we speak here
in Indian Law Resource Center,
my stop is in Alaska meeting
with Alaska native
women organization
that federal government just
give them $1 million to work
on their human rights issues.
And that we're working
how to implement both.
So we're having workshop
now as we speak in Alaska,
talking about how
to implement VAWA.
Some of the challenges
that we face has to do
with economic aspect of it.
For example, because of
the jurisdiction issues
between the non-Indian legal
system verses the Indian legal
system and how that can be
worked out and negotiated.
Who is going to pay
for those expenses?
And so it's an ongoing thing.
But one of the thing
that we feel very good is
that we have a lot
of good women,
native women, leading
this fight.
And I can name many of
them, Terry Henry, you know,
others who are leading
this fight nationally.
And so we are just supporting
them, and now working with them,
helping them fundraising.
A general worker from our
office is the head of one
of our senior lawyer from Basin,
Montana, she's leading this work
with Chris Foley
[phonetic spelling].
And we have Karla General
in our office here in DC.
She just went back to
work for her government
in Six Nations Territory.
But these are wonderful
people fighting
for this totally implement VAWA.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Right, right, great.
I know you also did some work
with the Seminoles in Florida
and gave them the opportunity
to buy back some land.
Could you tell us about that?
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Yes,
Seminole, these are, you know,
there's two group of Seminoles.
One is the traditional
Seminoles, and the other one
that is more successful
one, they have casinos.
They have protect.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Hard rock, right?
>> Armstrong Wiggins: We have
Seminoles, I think that was one
of my interesting experience.
Because they don't
believe in compromising.
They believe that they
need to be left alone.
They want to have their
own traditional ceremonies.
And they lost land and so
they used to borrow land
from citrus growers in Florida,
to do their green
dance ceremonies.
And so they look to us for help,
how to get land that they lost
to have their traditional
and then their homes,
to build their homes the way
they want, tipis, basically.
And so we represented them.
And I think that was very
difficult from my experience,
because they won't compromise.
In other words, it's
hard to negotiate
between non-Indian verses them.
But we were lucky to go outside
of Florida to look for help.
I don't know if you heard
about land foundation?
It's based in Santa
Fe, New Mexico.
It's a very rich family.
Patrick Lannan, one day, knocked
at my door here in DC and said,
in a blue jean, you know,
dressed like somebody
that don't have money.
And he said, I am Patrick Lannan
and I want to talk to you guys
about how we can help.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Help the Seminoles.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
Not only the Seminoles,
Indian Law Resource Center.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Oh.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: We
are interested in education.
We want to help tribal
government, technical schools.
We want to get them money.
And so I'm here.
I heard about you guys
and we want to talk.
And that's how we started.
And Patrick Lannan paid for
this huge land in Florida
for the Seminoles, $1.5 million.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Wow.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: From the
citrus growers that they used
to do their ceremonies.
And so now they have a land
that is not only the
Seminole have a land
to do their traditional work,
but this land will be
protected environmentally.
This land, they have bald
eagles, they have alligators,
and there's not in that
destructive way of development.
And then the other fight
we had with the state
of Florida was the Tipis.
Because they wanted to
build their own homes.
And because of rules
of building codes,
the Florida government said, no.
so we tried to get, you know,
all the newspaper on our side
to make, you know, kind
of challenge the state.
And state finally give in
and let them build
their own typical homes
to have their own
traditional ceremonies.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Wow.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: And
so that's a great story.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Now,
that's a success story, yeah.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: And the
other day I was riding the--
I ride the metro from
Washington, from Virginia to DC.
And there were some native
kids, high school kids.
And they were laughing
and joking.
And they come and sit by
me and start talking to me.
And I said, where you from?
And he said, I'm a
Seminole from Florida.
We're visiting Washington.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Wow.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: I said,
do you know Uncle Billy?
That's my uncle!
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Wow.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
How do you know my uncle?
Because I work with him.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Serendipity.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
They were excited.
A week later the uncle
called me and said--
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Nice, very nice.
Have there been any cases or
issues that you wanted to take
that you've been unable
to take at the Center.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
Oh, there's so many.
If we have, like some-- if we
get money from the government,
the European government
offered lots of money,
but we don't accept it.
Because sometimes there
are conditions of why.
There's so many cases, tenure
land title is so important
to us, legal rights
to their land.
And if you watch the world
changing toward our issues,
European begin to support
Indian thinking about how
to manage land, how to
manage natural resources,
and climate issues.
And so land titling
is very important
so that indigenous people
can manage their land.
Protected area, how
we protect our way
from World Wildlife Fund,
Conservation International
and others, that only follow
the money trail, especially USA.
But when that money
finished, they move back
to [inaudible] City, or
they move back to Roselyn,
because they don't have
money to stay there.
So then the bad guys move in
and destroy the environment.
And they don't respect
indigenous people land rights.
They only work with
the central government.
And so that's the problem.
If indigenous people
managed those areas,
those land like Bosawas
Nicaragua,
and many other people
in Brazil, you know.
Only the bone that fell
from these environmental
organization, they get money
from USAID goes to
the indigenous people.
But then when they move
out, indigenous people have
to face the poacher, the people
that cut their land
and their territory.
We would like to work
for them in Brazil.
We would like to work with
them with the Brazilian banks.
That is very, very bad against
Indian land rights issues,
take away Indian lands
by building the highways
and the dams and
stuff like that.
Do you know that the
[Foreign Language],
which is the Brazil
bank, has more money
than World Bank right now?
And so they give very
destructive development
that is not good for
indigenous people.
So we try to work with
educate these banks
and develop legal mechanism
to restrict indigenous
people land rights.
But we don't have all
that money to do that.
European are now beginning
to give some money.
They just created an
institute in Stockholm
about Indian land tenure issues.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Oh, wow.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: But
I don't know if it will go
to the indigenous people.
And that's the thing.
There are a lot of
discrimination about money given
to indigenous people also.
And because, you
know, intermediaries.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Right, right.
Leo, is there any case you
wish you could have taken?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa:
Most of the--
I mean, reason why
we don't take a lot
of cases is money, basically.
We can't represent all the
clients that we would like to.
So we are very selective
of the cases that we take,
especially looking
into the issues.
If we take a case,
we will, basically,
gain reform in the
politics of that country.
That's the main reason.
However, there are situations
where we start looking
to the case, documenting
the facts,
starting to interview local
authorities about the issues
that the indigenous
communities are concerned.
In the end, when we are about
to take the legal action,
and we have secured
some resources,
the issue is resolved.
So no case, right?
I can mention a few examples.
One is the [inaudible]
community.
It's a [inaudible] community
in the Peruvian Amazon,
close to the border with Brazil.
There was an interoceanic
highway was going to be built
with funds coming from both
the Brazil Development Bank
and the Inter-American
Development Bank that will,
basically, connect
Brazil [inaudible]
on the Brazil side
with Pucullpa Peru.
And will, basically,
divide up the land
where this community
was located.
And so we started to inquire
where the funds were coming,
the permits that these companies
had to build that road.
In the middle of that,
the [inaudible] the head
of this community started
to talk to civil society,
locally in Pucullpa,
and there nationally
in Lima, the capital of Peru.
So we started to make
some noise about it.
And in the middle of that,
the transportation
authorities started
to cancel all the permits.
They basically redesigned
the project, and as a result,
they weren't going to
divide up that community.
And so we had no case to take.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: OK.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: And
there were some cases like that.
But mainly it is a
lack of resources.
We are very selective about the
cases, because we actually want
to have a huge impact
on the country.
And we want one case to
benefit not only our client,
but also other communities
that are the same legal
and factual situation.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Right.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: The other
thing that we would like to,
is the new thinking between
United States all the way to,
probably, Argentina.
That most of the coastal
communities are indigenous land
and resources.
And now because of wind and new
energy system, they're going
to affect them in a different
way in indigenous community
without consulting with them,
without indigenous
people planning
to take from these wind.
They're going to set out
for energy provide use.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Oh, like
the wind farms, and-- yeah.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
The benefit doesn't go
to indigenous people.
It goes to Walmart, it
goes to, like in Mexico,
it goes to Corona, the factory,
the Corona beer company,
and other big corporations.
And so we've been to
us to help in that.
And Leo can talk about
that too, in Mexico.
What we just did was one
of the biggest project
in Latin America.
But it's going to happen.
Even in my territory,
in Moskito coast,
is where all the Atlantic
coast is where the wind is.
And it's Indian land.
And so now Indian land has
been challenged by governments.
One of the good thing is that
Indian Law Resource Center,
because of the negotiating
with all these states
for over 30 years in
Geneva, I was the founder
of the UN declaration,
beginning in 1977.
Tim and I was there
at the beginning.
I remember when we woke up
that morning, we couldn't get
out to go to our meetings
because the school bus came
from all over Europe
to see Indians, right?
Because that was the first
time we came to Europe,
to attend the United
Nation, 1977.
The working group
started in 1982.
And the declaration
was adopted in 2007.
Imagine how long we negotiated.
Especially with England was
the most difficult thing
because England didn't believe
that individual rights
is human rights,
so they will not support us.
And so we wanted consensus to be
developed in the United Nation.
And then the Organization of
American States, renegotiated
since 1989, to work
on the declaration.
And that is because Spain
wanted to celebrate 500 years
of discovery and wanted
to give money to the OAS,
and so they wanted to
come up with something
about indigenous people.
And, you know, OAS was
a good old boys place.
No NGOs would participate.
No Indians come there.
Only them elected people.
We said, no, we want to be
part of that negotiation.
And, as Canadian
ambassador said it,
that Indian people
kicked the OAS door open,
not only for indigenous
people, but for civil society,
and for NGOs, Non-Governmental
Organization.
And so, really, Indian Law
Resource Center was advising
their leaders, coming that
and giving legal advice.
And because of that, all member
states, whether OAS or the UN,
have a lot of respect for us,
because we are very serious
about these challenges and
try to, kind of, be balanced
and diplomatic about,
you know, our rights.
I am not just professional in
the Indian Law Resource Center,
I was Indian leader, you know.
So I can also keep the
lawyers in balance too.
And from the scientific
perspective,
as an electrical
engineer, you know.
So we have a different
view in this world
when we face these issues.
So it's very challenging.
And I hope that our young
people can also follow
that in the future.
We trying to train
our young leaders.
But it's very hard because
of the economic aspect
of Leo was talking about.
Because, you know, a
lot of young people,
a lot of our interns
or fellows that come
to our office want
to do what we do.
They love excitement,
but then they all left
to federal government
to pay back
after they become
lawyers or professionals.
I want other professional,
not just lawyers.
But they have to
pay back their--
>> Carrie N. Lyons: It's true.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
So it's very hard
to do human rights
work, you know.
And that's the challenges
that we face too.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: So, we have
a few more minutes, and I wanted
to open it up to questions,
if anybody has any.
So, yes, sir?
>> Audience: According you, sir,
over in Nicaragua, you cut out,
according to use
the Panama Canal,
construct with huge
Chinese companies.
I want to hear your view
about this canal construction.
I'm sure the environmental
destruction,
and effecting indigenous
peoples in the area.
Could you give me your
opinion about this?
>> Armstrong Wiggins: Yes.
Nicaragua government is
now populist government.
You know what populist
government means.
You have one here.
But there, more dictators
than here yet.
Because they have check
and balance here in
the United States.
I hope we don't lose
that check and balances.
I hope we hang on to that
so we can challenge the
executive branch.
But in Nicaragua, they control
all of the government branches,
whether the legislative,
the legal branches,
and the military, the police,
and control the election
process also.
And so they negotiated with this
Chinese guy, individual guy,
and they decided to pass
this Law 84 that is very,
very bad against
indigenous people
and peasants-- poor people.
And then Nicaragua Lake,
it is the biggest lake
that have freshwater, and
we have freshwater shark,
and that freshwater species.
Nicaragua Lake give
water supply--
drinking water to
Chontales, which is one
of the biggest states.
Or [foreign language].
And then Rivas, which
is another big state
that get drinking water.
Can you imagine opening
up a canal
from the Pacific
to the Atlantic.
Then, when you go to the
Atlantic, you're dealing
with indigenous people,
the Rama Indian and Creole,
block communities that feel like
they are also, like, indigenous.
They live there.
And they got to live
for themselves, so
a block community.
Their land is also owned
collectively, not individually.
And all that is going
to be affected.
Can you imagine all
the shark will die
when saltwater comes in?
And so everybody is
fighting against that.
And seems like the guy
who's the individual,
very rich individual, it looks
like he lost a lot of money
in the crisis in China
with the stock market.
And so it's kind of calmed down.
We are hoping that Chinese
government is not behind that.
And we are hoping that because
Panama Canal is just being
renovated, make it wider,
the big ship can pass.
The reason they wanted to
do it through Nicaragua is
because Asian ships,
some of them are huge,
that couldn't go through Panama.
So they wanted to build a canal
bigger, through Nicaragua.
But what happened is Nicaragua
is wider, longer to cross,
more expensive, and one
of the biggest problem is,
Nicaraguan government
cannot protect
from terrorist attack
against a ship.
So it has to be very
powerful country to protect
like how US protect
Panama Canal.
And it has to be China.
But China is not that
far, yet, to do say-so.
We don't know because we
understand the US is also
pushing China not to do that.
So it's on hold right now.
But we don't know what
can happen going forward.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Did
you have a question?
Yeah, yeah?
>> Audience: [inaudible]
for your presentation.
For one, you have a very
good insight about a problem,
and you recognize it
according to your efforts.
But, on the other hand, I think
you are saying you cannot have a
resources to tackle
individual cases.
The problem is you allow them
to divide individual then,
eventually, you have
a nation from them
where they face all
individual who want to donate,
but they don't have the
resource, because their land,
their home, their estate, their
income are all victimized.
So eventually, you are
going to have some kind
of unjust influence
by those big donors,
maybe financial institution,
maybe some NGO.
They get their money from
Chamber of Commerce, or lawyers.
So I think, probably,
eventually, you may have dues,
but you may have a
better [inaudible]
and you've victimized
all your people.
So how you going to solve that,
unless you try some effort?
How do you connect with
other good people whose civic
organization may not be
an NGO, may not be NAACP?
But you must have
somebody to work with you
to solve the individual problem.
Otherwise you are going
to have vicious cycle.
So I just want to
know, would you be able
to do some effort in that?
Because that would
be American problem
that would be Indian
problem too.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: I'm not
really sure of the question.
>> What is the question,
I don't know.
>> Audience: That question
is, can you be able
to solve the individual
problem based off
of justice and fairness?
You are talking about
America have check
and balance, but
I don't think so.
Because everything is
controlled by those
in bloody interest group.
And the individual
are not protected.
So you are basing it on private
donation that individual cases.
If they don't want to donate,
they don't have resources
to donate because
they are victimized.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Right, well, I think.
>> Audience: -- donation,
unless, I said,
the big corporation or
the financial institution
who are working to
victimize you even further.
Maybe individually you
don't even have that.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: Well,
I'm not really sure what the
question is, but I think it goes
to the difference between taking
on cases collectively
or individually.
>> The basic question is
really, you must do some cost
about justice and fairness.
Not based on who is
giving you donation.
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
Right, right.
And, I mean, I think you've
somewhat addressed those
questions when you talk
about how you pick cases
and where you get the
money from and, yeah.
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: Yeah,
so thank you for your question.
There are some issues, maybe,
that will help you,
help all of us.
We have various different
projects through which we try
to reform laws and policies
that will, eventually,
improve the situation
at whole communities
and individual members
of that communities,
in developing countries
and in the US.
One of those programs
is actually in nature,
where we take a case,
we represent a community
or a people against, it
might be a government agency
or a company, and we use the
legal system of that country.
Other programs include
influencing policies
of public sector financial
institutions, like, for example,
the World Bank Group, where you
will find International Monetary
Fund, the International
Financial Corporation,
the International
Bank Reconstruction.
The government will not hold
bank, and other regional banks,
like, for example, the
Inter-American Government back.
And what we've done since the
80s and the [inaudible] program,
where we work on policies,
is push these banks
to create a policy, a safer
policy that aims preventing harm
to communities and
the environment,
through the projects
that they finance.
And so, even though, some
countries and some donors
with money with pressure these
institutions to have policies.
So that those getting funds
from these institutions,
in some cases, in
developing countries,
in other trans-national
corporations operating
in developing countries,
would have to comply
with the safe parts
of this policy.
For example, we got the
World Bank, in 1981,
to adopt the first
indigenous people's policy.
In 2006, we got the
Inter-American Development Bank,
for the first time, to
approve an operational policy
on indigenous peoples.
We are now working
with indigenous peoples
in our organization in Brazil
to get the Brazilian
Development Bank
to develop its first operational
policy on indigenous peoples.
And, at the same time,
we educate donors how important
it is to provide support
to indigenous peoples
from the ground
that are fighting corruption,
that are fighting
government agencies trying
to get their lands, conservation
organizations trying
to manage their natural
resources.
And sometimes we get
supports, sometimes not.
But we find ways to work through
the legal system of the country
or this international
organization.
So that we can either get
an international instrument,
like the declarations on the
rights of indigenous peoples,
or ban policies on indigenous
peoples in an actual case
to change the way indigenous
peoples are treated sometimes.
I hope that clarifies
this a bit.
>> Armstrong Wiggins: I think
also, to try to understand,
when you say, a vicious
circle, what I want you
to understand that, we,
from our perspective,
we do respect collective
and individual rights.
We respect that.
I was jailed in my territory,
my people defended me.
That's why I'm alive.
I was arrested in Managua,
Nicaragua, in the capital
from my office, close to
the [inaudible] office.
I was defended through
my individual rights,
not collective rights,
through my villages, OK?
So, sometimes it benefits us
and we respect one aspect of it.
But let me just tell you one
example what just happened
to us not too long ago.
We, trying to get
money from law offices,
but there're sometimes
conflict of interest.
We had been trying to get
money from corporation,
but sometimes there
might be conflict
of interest, from corporation.
We got some money
from Mitsubishi Foundation
in New York.
It's this Japanese car
maker's foundation.
We decided, maybe, we can get
that to work with the red issue
that you heard about,
talk about.
This is environmental issue.
Environmental is know what
is red, a red program.
The European come up with a
list environmental thinking.
The first one is gift,
then now red, OK?
Which mean the, what they were,
if you have a lot of trees,
you can get money from your
trees that is in your yard or is
in your community, OK?
That's red program.
So Mitsubishi was
interested in that.
But when we met with that, we
didn't know when we decided
to represent indigenous people
in Mexico about the wind issues
that I just talk about.
One of the biggest money
was coming from Mitsubishi
and Inter-American
Development Bank.
And so Mitsubishi said, you
stop representing the Indians
or we will not give
you the money.
And we said, we will not stop
it, you can stop the money.
And that's what we did, OK?
Something that--
>> Carrie N. Lyons:
It's a balance, yeah.
>> Armstrong Wiggins:
It's a balance.
So I just wanted to
clarify that too.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: So
I think we have time
for one last question.
>> Audience: You have in
Guatemala, which has almost half
of its population indigenous.
And they have been
considering a law
that would recognize
indigenous law to some degree.
But it stalled, in part,
because of objections
from business communities
that might be able
to exploit natural
resources, indigenous lands,
and for other reasons.
So I wanted to know if you could
discuss how can indigenous law,
with its main emphasis
on collective property,
collective right, coexist
with, like, the national laws
of a country like Guatemala that
emphasizes individual rights?
How can you have those
two function and coexist?
>> Leonardo A. Crippa: There
are some precedents still
in Guatemala.
I remember a decision issued
by the Conditional Court
where it was a Supreme Court
case against [inaudible],
a member of my community,
after the Maya approached his
community and applies a sanction
against him because
of behavior that was
against the community's
traditions.
But, anyway, his case ended
up in the Guatemala
criminal system.
So that case brought to
the conventional courts,
the conditional court
basically said indigenous people
of Guatemala have a legal system
in which they can
resort authorities.
And a policy where criminal
issues have been addressed
by the own community, the
state courts cannot reduce
to persecute those that
haven't already been sanctioned
by traditional groups.
So that court, the
traditional court,
applied what is non-criminal
law.
They [inaudible], which
means, no one tell me subject
to criminal charges once.
But that's just one
example, and one precedent.
And I remember this because a
lawmaker [inaudible] was one
of the authorities [inaudible]
members of my community.
And the controversy around
collective land rights
and the country's
legal system oriented
to protect private property,
that's not such a
big controversy
because there are already
laws in Guatemala that tend
to protect collective lands.
Like, for example, the
law that the created the--
it is called the
[foreign language].
That basically will execute and
enforce all of the agrarian laws
that were passed by
Congress in Guatemala.
And that law, it tries to
provide some protection
for peasant communities.
In that way, it was
good objective.
But it wasn't, at the same time,
not as good because indigenous
peoples were included there
as peasant communities,
until we solved all
of the agrarian policies
are applied
to indigenous communities
as though they were
peasant communities,
without consider their legal
nature as indigenous people.
We call this right are
recognized by international law
in the paper and so forth.
So there are some precedents
in both court positions
and in actual legislation
that tend
to protect collective
[inaudible] lands.
But, unfortunately, Guatemala,
there is no actual legislation
that recognizes indigenous
people's communities legal
personality, nor their
collective ownership
over the lands that
they possess.
And that is why we started them,
whenever there is a conservation
project on Indian lands,
or a constructive energy
project on native lands.
But, I would say, the best way
to work towards a reconciliation
of these different laws
or legal approaches is
by making indigenous
peoples sit at the table
and have an ad hoc
conversation with them.
So that when we stand here,
them, and they can participate
in the development
of [inaudible].
And that is something that
already happened in Peru.
The consultation
that was [inaudible].
>> Armstrong Wiggins: I think
it's a very good question,
and sometimes have
me sleepless nights.
And I remember when Kofi Annan
was the Secretary-General
of the UN.
He went to Bolivia for the first
time, and then he came back.
And he called me up and
said, can we have lunch?
So I had lunch with him
right at 8th Street.
Now we get famous.
And one of Kofi Annan
question to me was Armstrong.
I know that Bolivian
are indigenous majority,
just like Guatemala.
But he didn't go to Guatemala,
he was coming from Bolivia.
And he said, but how
can we find a leader
that can bring everybody
together instead
of taking what happened
to them to take to go
against the minority,
non-indigenous people.
How we find, in Bolivia,
something what happened
in South Africa, you know,
by South African leader?
And so it's a tough question.
I said, I don't have the answer.
We just-- education is key
to do, to do that, you know,
like what happened
in South Africa.
Even though he was in jail
that long, became president
and he worked with everybody
and pulled everybody together.
Guatemala situation
is the same thing.
And yet, if you think
about in China,
it's a communist country, right?
China? China economy is
taking all of our bills here
in the United States
because China keep pulling
out of our debt, right?
And so, what's going on in
China is now they're bringing
to their politburo,
all the rich people.
But they can't question
the collectivity,
the corporative system
of Chinese system
of government, you know.
So one of the thing that
we're thinking, hoping,
is that we get education to
all indigenous communities.
That they can become
voting power.
And it's not hard.
In Guatemala, probably
60% in majority.
Can you imagine if they vote in
what your founding fathers said,
our founding fathers said here?
That educated people
can vote the right way
that who they believe
can be a good leader.
That's not what happened
in Guatemala, OK?
So if they can vote their
own president, Mayan leader
like [inaudible] will
become the president.
But we're not there yet.
Even Inter-American Court of
Human Rights, in San Jose,
Costa Rica, which is the OAS
Inter-American System ruled
with the case of
Yatama vs. Nicaragua.
And they ruled in favor
of indigenous people
have the rights
to have election
according to their history,
according to their
culture, not enforced
by the capital city
political parties.
If that happened in Guatemala,
and I'm Indian person can be
offered this in Guatemala.
But we're not there yet.
And so if Indian person can
be in Guatemala, president,
and negotiate with the
business community,
I'm sure they can meet
in the middle ground
to have a better life for
indigenous [inaudible].
They can negotiate that.
But we're not there yet.
But it will happen,
I'm telling you.
Not in my lifetime,
but in the future,
that probably will happen,
because they're the majority.
>> Carrie N. Lyons: OK,
so I'm getting the
signal we should wrap up.
But I'd like to thank you
both again for coming out.
This was wonderful.
We are so grateful
to have you here.
And I'd also like
to thank everybody
for spending time with us today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.